welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
from simply learning today we're going
to talk about Google Display Network so
thanks for joining and let's get started
so I want you to imagine having the
world at your fingertips especially when
it comes to advertising imagine having
the entire world at your fingertips for
advertising so just imagine you have the
ability to advertise your brand to any
website in the world can you imagine
that
well imagine having that entirety at
your fingertips the entire world so it's
not really an imagination
so no need to imagine anymore because
Google Ads has come to the rescue so no
need to imagine the world is at your
fingertips and why is it your fingertips
because of Google and specifically
Google Display Network okay so we're
gonna talk about what the Google Display
Network is so let's start out by asking
the question or answering the question
what is the Google Display Network so
Google has two networks basically one
the search network one the Display
Network so you as an advertiser if you
want to advertise on Google you have a
choice
can I go with Google search or can I go
with the Display Network well the search
network is for Google search only so if
you want to advertise when somebody
types in a keyword query and you want
your ad to show up that's the search
network so it looks something like this
somebody types in a keyword data science
and lo and behold ads show up I mean
here you can see the first ad from
simply learn why did that ad show up
because simply learn was bidding on the
keyword data science and so that's how
the search network works you bid on
keywords somebody types on those
keywords and your ads show up in the
search engine results at the top above
organic listings so that's the search
Network and it just simply comprises of
ads that respond to what people are
query ok the Display Network is a little
bit
different so that's the search Network
today we're going to talk about the
Display Network
okay the display network is a little bit
different so imagine you're on the
lookout for a new shoe on Amazon as an
example but you don't have end up buying
the shoe you're looking at shoes you
don't buy it well you might have noticed
in the past you've done something like
that
whether it be shoes or shirts or codes
or belts or cars or radios or headphones
or phones it doesn't really matter you
might have been looking at something and
then notice an ad show might have been
exactly that same product or might have
been something similar to the product
you were looking at but on the same
website so why does that happen well it
happens because Google's Display Network
specifically remarketing which we'll
talk about so on Google's Display
Network you have the option to advertise
as somebody's been on your website so
that's one of the powers and one of the
features of Google's Display Network and
that's remarketing or retargeting
somebody that's looked at your product
so let's take a little bit of a deeper
dive into how the Display Network works
so if your customer you go to a website
and you leave that website again from a
remarketing perspective your product can
appear on another site okay so that's
remarketing so you can retarget that
person who's been to your site so that's
again one great example of how to use
this play network in google terms would
call it remarketing and again somebody
goes to your website they leave in this
example not buying something it could be
a technology company where we want
somebody to watch a video or download a
PDF ok whatever they do that that you
want them to do but they don't actually
do it then you can go back and retarget
them so if they actually go to a page
and look at your product but don't buy
that product then you have the
opportunity to advertise them again so
the whole idea is if you advertise them
again Wow
that person can say ok I remember that
I was in still interested in that
product let me go back and purchase that
product so they go back to the side and
make the purchase so that's again the
power of the Display Network you can
reach people who up in to your site
before so let's take another look here
so retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browser cookies to add
website visitors to your audience so let
me just summarize that for you so if you
want to use the Display Network and you
want to target people who've been to
your website well you need to add a
simple script or pixel if you will to
your website that's all and so when
somebody comes to your website they're
gonna get cookie and that cookie is
stored in their browser and so that's an
important piece of the whole process
because that's how Google determines who
that visitor is so without that cookie
then Google won't know to show their ad
your ad to them again so that's the
first piece in all this so when somebody
does get cookie they're gonna be added
to that audience and so when we say
audience we mean you as an advertiser to
finding who you want to retarget to so
in this example we're talking about
people who have looked at a product and
didn't purchase that could be a whole
audience in itself people who look at a
product and don't purchase it could be
everyone who comes to your website it
could be only returning users it could
be only new users you define the
audience but however you define that
audience they're gonna get cookie and
placed on a list and when they're placed
in that list they're gonna get shown the
ad again so past visitors will see your
product ads when they're browsing the
web watching videos on YouTube going
through new sites and so on
so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're gonna be
able to see your ad because Google's
Display Network is much more than just
web sites it's also YouTube it's also
news feeds it's also social networking
sites so there's a lot involved with
Google's Display Network so the network
involves several websites that are
partnered up with Google along with the
likes of YouTube along with the likes of
mains
other websites in fact these websites
together tally up to more than two
million that encompasses more than 90%
of the internet so you can imagine
Google's Display Network is just made up
of a bunch of websites including YouTube
okay so you have the opportunity to
really reach somebody that's been to
your website before so again if they're
passed visitors and they looked at a
product and then it purchased it you
have an opportunity to really put your
ad in front of them on a lot of
different websites so that's just an
intro about the Display Network
remarketing is just one benefit but
let's take a step back so we dome in the
deep end with remarketing we'll just
separate out the two again just so
you're clear on what the Display Network
is versus the search Network well let's
go some through some of the differences
so Display Network on the Left search
Network on the right so - Display
Network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top a funnel why do we say
top a funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product ok the Display Network
we know remarketing is a benefit but
usually its bottom of funnel like brand
awareness so if nobody knows who your
brand is what your brand is or what you
have to offer what your services are
then the Display Network remember made
up a millions of websites you have the
operation you put your ad out there okay
so display bottom of funnel search
Network top of funnel somebody actively
looking for something take a look at
some other differences here so Display
Network easier to advertise products
that don't satisfy an immediate need
this is true because again if you have a
new product you want to get that product
out there you want people to just know
about it some people may not be ready to
buy that product but at Lee
they're gonna know what the products
about on the search Network on the other
hand if somebody's looking for something
like a particular product that you're
offering then they could type in a
keyword that describes that product in
whim your ad can appear at the top okay
remember top of file so products and
services usually fulfill a particular
requirement now the display network can
be used to familiarize users to your
brand so again going back to remarketing
somebody comes to your website they
really don't know who you are well you
can reach back out to them
on the Display Network with another ad
retargeting and that's how you can get
users familiar with your brand we're on
the search Network users are shown ads
based on what they search for so it
doesn't really matter if they know your
brand or not hey if they're looking for
something then they're ready to buy and
you have that product at the right price
then the chance of them converting a
pretty good so you're at the right place
at the right time
where the display networks all about
familiarity retargeting the people with
your brand getting your brand out there
getting your product out there in front
of millions of people now on the Display
Network users are shown these ads and
over a million different websites so
with the Display Network you have the
opportunity to kind of hone in and pick
and choose those websites we're on the
de search network users have shown ads
in Google Apps and on the search engines
so you have the opportunity to place
your ads not just on desktop search but
also on mobile and also on apps whereas
again the Display Network is made up of
much more it's made up of websites
YouTube apps etc okay the Display
Network has a multitude of different
formats okay when we say different
formats we mean text ads image ads rich
media ads meaning ads that have some
functionality to it like movement and
then video ads where the search network
is really only text ads and I say really
only text ads where you can have image
ads those are called shopping ads but
mainly it's text ads we're Display
Network you have an option between text
image rich media or video s so you can
see the different
is here really there are big differences
between the two networks where search
you're just really responding what
somebody's looking for they're really
active and ready to go
display hey you're trying to reach out
to these people you're trying to
introduce them to something and in some
cases with remarketing you're reaching
out to them again okay you're trying to
get them familiar with your product and
brand and you're trying to do that via
video via rich media via regular image
ad via text ad so you're trying to do it
in a multitude of formats so again
bottom of funnel for display top a
funnel for search now we've already
mentioned display ads can be found any
number of different formats so that's
important to know so for example text
ads so we know what a text ad looks like
on the search Network very similar on
the Display Network so you have a
headline you have some tags Chevy URL so
that's a text ad so text ads on display
are very similar to how they look on
search rich media ads so these type of
ads enable more user engagement with
videos animation text combinations and
more so you usually have some movement
going on here with rich media ads some
animation something that you're going to
likely engage with okay so with display
you have the opportunity to serve a rich
media ads and the whole idea is you want
to really grab somebody's attention
because display is bottom of funnel
we're trying to introduce our brand to
somebody so putting something engaging
in front of them is gonna get them to
take notice of your product and brand we
have regular image ads so these ads let
you use relevant images layouts and
different backgrounds and colors so you
can use a static image with some
messaging with it again there are some
best practices involved here with image
ads you're really you're trying to
introduce your product and brand to
somebody you want to make it stand out
and pop and then of course video ads so
video ads are served up on YouTube and
across a multitude of websites on
Google's Display Network remember
Google's Display Network is made up of
millions of sites some sites allow for
video advertising so it's not just
limited to YouTube it can be used
a multitude of sites across the slay
network so that's an intro to the
Display Network those are the
differences between search and display
now let's go through the steps of how to
set up a campaign in Google Ads using
the Display Network as our option so
here I am I'm in Google Ads
I'm in an account and I want to set up a
campaign on the Display Network so you
can see here if I'm in Google Ads I've
selected display campaigns I can already
see I have some Display Network campaign
set up in fact they're all remarketing
campaigns
it's a remarkable it's or a description
okay so it could be somebody looking at
a particular product they get cookie
meaning that text file is gonna sit on
their browser and then they're gonna see
your ad the next time you're on Google's
Display Network wherever site they may
be so we're reaching out to somebody who
fits a particular description okay so if
we're gonna set up a display campaign
meaning a campaign on Google's Display
Network we want to go to campaigns and
we want to click on the plus button here
and we're just gonna say new campaign
now we have the opportunity now to pick
and choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display in video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search Network but if
you're just really trying to just
promote your brand you may go with
display because remember you have the
option to get your ad in front of
millions of websites we're gonna choose
brand awareness and reach okay and we're
going to choose the campaign type so
here you have display we want to run
different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to run it for
running video we can reach and engage
viewers on YouTube and across the web
meaning other websites okay which shoes
display here so we're going to go ahead
and just put our website in there
so our business's website
and when that loads up we're gonna have
a number of different options available
to us so here we can name our campaign
okay so here you can see brand awareness
and Reach is the name of our campaign
and for now we're just gonna protest now
we have the opportunity to choose a
location here we're gonna choose the
United States we have just like a search
campaign we also have languages and
options so we search you have locations
and languages same thing on display so
we're gonna target English as our
language and what are we trying to do
what are we focusing on well we want to
get a product out there so we're gonna
choose impressions viewable impressions
that's really what we want to focus on
we want people to see our ad okay so an
impression is the number of times
somebody sees your ad okay so we have a
viewable impressions that's what we want
people to do we want them to see our ad
and if you take a peek over here on the
right side you can see your targeting's
reach so we can reach over 10 billion
plus in impressions meaning that's a lot
of eyeballs the number of people looking
at our ad right now is over 10 million
plus okay so that's it just gives you
the scope and some idea of how big
Google's Display Network is so just like
search we could set a budget I'm just
gonna choose $100 for now and I can
choose how to deliver that budget just
like on search I have standard
accelerated I can ask Google to speed up
the spend or I could just do regular
stand or which means they're going to
spend my budget evenly over a period of
time over the course of the day now
remember with Display Network we have
different options on ad types we have
text ads rich media ads regular image
ads and video so we can rotate our ads
how we like so we could say hey look I
want to run my best performing ads okay
so that means I want Google to optimize
for me meaning if I have an ad that's
performing better than some others then
I'm going to let Google run that one
more and that's the one I would
recommend but you do have other options
here you can just have them rotate
evenly you can say
hey optimized for conversions but it's
really remember our goal here for
display is to get impressions eyeballs
we're not interested in top of funnel
conversions in here we could say rotate
evenly and that's not supported for
display so really our best option here
is prefer best performing ads we want
our best performing ads to run ok we
have an option to schedule them we have
an option to start and ok and we have an
option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
Google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to X times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or a group okay so we could set the
limit ourselves and we can let Google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions and then we have the
opportunity to set up or a group no the
ad group is the same as the search
Network the a group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're gonna choose our audience and if
we're not remarketing we still have the
opportunity to choose our audience so if
I'm a tech company and I just type in
tech then Google is gonna give me some
options here so here I can choose some
tech companies technology products new
inventions etc or I can choose some
ideas that Google has in mind for
audiences like they have an in market
audience so this is based on network
system and services network management
so the bottom line is Google is giving
me suggestions on who I can target Maya
to ok that's what really what this is
choosing your audience now you don't
have to choose anything here in fact you
can just clear all and be done with that
now you can go down to demographics now
I can pick and choose based on gender I
could pick and choose based on
age parental status and household income
really depending on who you're
advertising - that's really what it
comes down to it okay so you have
demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of Google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience and we're gonna talk
about that here in a minute but this is
all part of the setup for the campaign
so I'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you could set up a
bid just like you want on the search
Network and then you have the option to
choose your app so that's part of the
campaign set up so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image add rich media and video
or text once you choose your ad then you
pretty much have your campaign set up
now we're gonna want we get after we set
it up but that's pretty much the steps
in terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ads to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they've looked at a product or
they looked at a particular page so if
you're gonna retarget two people then as
a best practice I would set up the
audience in Google Analytics so Google
Analytics talks to Google Ads in fact
you can link up the two in analytics so
regardless of whether you're creating a
display campaign or search campaign you
want to link up analytics with Google
Ads so you can see we've done that here
okay now that we've linked the two up we
could set up an audience in Google
Analytics for use on a remarketing
campaign on Google's Display Network so
here you can see I have audiences set up
if you
just create a new audience you can do
that so I click new audience here here I
can choose choose returning users or new
users these are audiences that Google
has set up by default I can create a new
one if I want so I could say hey I want
to target you know 18 to 24 old males
who speak English for example and who
came from mobile so if I go here
technology I'm gonna say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks English I'm gonna
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if I go ahead and click
apply I'm gonna name my audience
18 24 year old male English mobile one
thing about remarketing on the Display
Network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel may be six
months long if they're buying a pair of
shoes then the funnel may be seven days
long maybe even shorter so it really
depends on your business the default is
thirty days so if you go with 30 days
and that means any 18 to 24 year old
male who speaks English and comes from
mobile is gonna get cookie and that
cookies gonna live for 30 days so if I
click next step I can go ahead and
publish it I can say I want this to be
available in my Google Ads account so
I'm gonna go ahead and pick my account
and it'll be available in that account
so I'll choose my account and then go
ahead and click publish so now this
audience list is gonna be available for
me to use in my display campaign when I
go to choose my audience so if I go back
to Google Ads so Google Ads and Google
Analytics talk to one another why
because they're linked and so now when I
go to actually set up my ad group and
I'm choosing remarketing I can go ahead
and choose that audience list so for
example this campaign that's already set
up I can go ahead and choose to set up
another aggghhhh
with that particular audience list so if
I choose new a group and now I'm going
to search for the audience I just set up
so here you go just a search and here's
my audience I'm gonna select my audience
and I'm gonna now use this audience in
my ad group from Myra marketing campaign
so now all I need to do is align the
right ad with this audience so that's
how remarketing works you choose your
audience list you set up your ads
remember you have different ad formats
video rich media image and text and the
whole idea beyond remarketing is you
know who your audience is you know what
you want to say to them so your ads
should really encompass that message the
message of what you want to say to that
particular group in this case 18 to 24
year old male who speak English who came
to your site from mobile so if you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the Display Network to your
advantage
remember bottom of the funnel the goal
of our campaign is just get our ad out
there so that people recognize our brand
or services our product so when you
actually go to set up an ad grow you
don't have to choose an audience to
retarget - you do have other options so
if I look at this I group here you can
see I have image ads already set up so
where do I want these image ads to
appear so I do have options available to
me in the Display Network so if I choose
keywords then that means if I go ahead
and add a keyword then what Google is
going to do is contextually place my
image ad on a website that fits the
description or matches that keyword so
if I add one or two or three keywords
then what Google is gonna do is you know
look at that keyword and it's gonna map
a website on the Display Network using
those keywords so that's keywords now
you got to be careful here because it's
a broad way
advertising meaning your ads could
appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing Google to
match the the website with the keywords
you choose
so that's choosing keywords audiences
again audiences are there if you want to
retarget so if your retargeting you can
set up your audience in analytics in
fact that's the best practice so again
if I go back to analytics and I go back
to admin under my property audiences I
can go ahead and choose my audience to
be used in Google Ads so that's using
audiences on a display campaign on
Google's Display Network when we're
setting up our campaign we add an option
to choose demographics so we can exclude
a demographic if we wanted to we can
always go back and exclude a demographic
just by removing them from the a group
notice if we choose all demographics we
can actually then see over a period of
time in Google ads how many people based
on this particular age group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw our ad but not only saw our ad that
would be impressions but clicked on our
ad and how much they spent per click and
how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
Display Network okay so that's them a
graphics I can also use topics so I can
tick I can choose a particular topic to
advertise on so if I choose topics I can
choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or I can drill down on
Google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see online
communities if I choose that one I can
see there are other subcategories under
online communities okay I can choose the
whole category of science or I can drill
down to see what subcategories are under
science so I can do that for any one of
these topic categories and if I choose a
category notice that's where Google is
going to place my ad what
I select again notice upper right here I
can take a sneak peek at how many
eyeballs go Google is expecting to see
my ad so here by choosing astronomy and
science I have three hundred ten million
impressions but so many potential
eyeballs can look at my ad so if you're
setting up a Display Network campaign
you can choose keywords you could choose
demographics or you could choose topics
now if you decide not to go with a topic
then your last option here is placements
so I can pick and choose a specific
placement if there's a particular
website that I want to advertise on
let's just say New York Times comm or or
LA Times calm or webmd.com you remember
there are over two main websites on
Google's Display Network so I can pick
and choose specifically where I want my
ants to be displayed now when you're
done choosing your audience or your
keywords or your demographics your
topics or your specific placements you
can always then go to your placements
and then click on where ads showed and
so now over this particular time frame
I'm gonna be able to see where my ads
have been shown and so now I can see my
ads have been shown my mobile apps and
on particular websites now if you don't
like any of the particular websites that
your ad is showing on you can always
select it and you can always exclude it
can exclude it from the ad group or the
campaign okay so that's how you manage
where your ads are showing up on
Google's Display Network again you can
go ahead and go to where ads are shown
under placements and over that
particular period of time Google's gonna
show you where your ads been shown and
if you don't like that placement then
you can always just exclude it or if you
don't like the performance meaning
you're not getting many impressions or
you're not getting any clicks or the
click-through rates very low you can go
ahead and exclude it so this is an
opportunity for you the advertiser to
take control
over where your ads are shown so in
summary when you set up a display
campaign on Google's Display Network you
have options if your remarketing you're
gonna choose your audience gonna choose
your audience using a list you created
in Google Analytics you're on the
Display Network not remarketing you have
the option you can choose a keyword and
have Google place your ad on a website
that fits the description of that
keyword you could choose specific
demographics you could choose a topic or
subtopic category or you can choose a
specific placement okay those are all
the options available to you
when you run your ad on Google's Display
Network now let's go back and take a
look at some of the advantages of the
Google Display Network so I just went
over with you how to actually create a
campaign and an ad group
I actually went over how to set up a
marketing campaign and set up a
marketing list and analytics and I went
over all the differences between the
search Network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the Display Network we can
provide advanced targeting meaning I can
particularly point to a specific website
that I want to advertise on so that's
what I mean by advanced targeting or if
I don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds I can
exclude them or I can really pick and
choose a specific audience that I want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done with an analytics or Google Ads so
advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look-alike audiences that
can be created based on the audience you
usually advertise to so in other words
we can really hone in and pick and
choose who we want to advertise to
another advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
Network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the Display Network you can
pick and choose who you want to
advertise
- and pick and choose where you want to
advertise so you can really advertise on
website to get a lot of traffic may not
have a lot of competition and therefore
may not cost as much so if you compare
to traditional forms of advertising like
TV or radio display advertising reaching
a large broader audience is a lot
cheaper you can do advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
advanced tracking we're talking about
again remarketing we can really pick and
choose who we want to remark it to and
cookie them and pick and choose how long
they are gonna be cookie so we talked
about advanced tracking that's what
we're really talking about so we can
also talk about how many times our ad is
shown to somebody we really can pick and
choose how many times we want somebody
actually see our ad on a site based on
performance okay let's take a look at
some other advantages the ability to
advertise your brand to a broader
audience can Google Ads over 2 million
websites so we can pick and choose where
really where we want our ads to show up
again it can be by topic can be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific websites so we can create the
man for our product and what we mean by
that we can create really cool ads
member rich media ads video ads these
are all engaging type of ads those are
ad types on the Display Network we
create engaging type of ads it's going
to appeal to somebody and they're going
to engage so we have that opportunity
just based on the different ad types
course increasing web traffic we can't
say that enough if you're advertising on
Google's Display Network you have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
millions of people get in front of our
ads in front of millions people we have
the opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats search Network only has text ads
here we have text we have rich media we
have image we have video so all these
types of ad formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways again remark attain our
product the services of the big big big
vonage using Google's Display Network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do it we want them to do we can
cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailored to that
audience so those are all the advantages
those are all the ways in which you
could take advantage of Google's Display
Network so if you have anything to add
please feel free to add a comment below
this video we'd love to hear from you if
you don't good luck and setting up your
Google display campaign if you need any
more information we're here we're at
simply learn to come thank you so much
and I appreciate your time look forward
to seeing you in the future
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here